[Music]
foreign
and scientific research move on
consumers today are looking for more
healthy or ethical choices in their
day-to-day lives where does this leave
companies whose Industries are falling
out of fashion Industries like fossil
fuels fast food big tobacco some of them
have tried to reinvent themselves but
can controversial companies ever really
change and what does that real change
look like these are some of the
questions I'll be asking in this
discussion with Moira Gilchrist vice
president of strategic Communications
for Philip Morris International and
Chris blackhurst formerly the editor of
the independent and a business
journalist
this discussion is also sponsored by PMI
but that doesn't mean we'll shy away
from the difficult questions for the big
tobacco company this discussion comes
after spectator editor Fraser Nelson's
interview with PMI CEO yashik where
Fraser challenged yashik on some of the
most burning questions surrounding pmi's
work and you can hear that as a podcast
on The Spectators website today I'll be
focusing more on the challenges that
various controversial Industries face in
their respective quests to reinvent
themselves so Chris and Moira thank you
so much for joining me on spectator TV
now Moreau Philip Morris International
is known as one of the world's largest
tobacco companies but now you're saying
that you're working for a smoke-free
future why
well I think the story of why goes back
to even before I joined the company
um you know the the realization that
smoking causes serious disease and
premature death obviously it happened in
the 1990s around about there and our
then CEO
um decided okay we understand there's a
problem with the product we have to set
out to do something about that
um so in the early 2000s the company
started to investigate scientifically
was there something that could be done
to reduce the amount of damage that
smoking causes and so a research program
was started it was all very hush-hush in
the company fast forward a bit I joined
in in 2006 when there was a desire to
really ramp up the company's ability to
to really investigate whether it was
possible to create better products that
ultimately could replace cigarettes and
they hired people like me from the
pharmaceutical industry to come in and
help the company learn how to do
development to the highest possible
standards how to do scientific
assessment to the highest possible
standards to withstand scrutiny from
Regulators from scientific community and
and consumers as well
and then unfolded another
um a decade or more
um until we had a product and we had
fantastic science showing that it was a
better choice is a better choice and
continuing to smoke
um we put it on the market and adult
smokers wanted to use it and and
switched and so in 2016 we announced
that that was going to be the future of
the company and that's heated tobacco
not smoking right um so we have a range
of different products all all of them
have one thing in common and that's that
they don't burn tobacco so it's the
burning of tobacco that causes the
production of the vast majority of the
harmful chemicals that end up causing
smoking related disease so we have a you
know a range of different products none
of them burn tobacco we have heated
tobacco we have something called
nicotine pouches we also have electronic
cigarettes and our aim is that this
range of products ultimately will
replace cigarettes and will no longer be
in the combustible cigarette Market you
have a lot of critics and your critics
cool there's a pseudo transformation
they point to the fact that the majority
of your Revenue still comes from
cigarettes despite as you've just drawn
out you know Decades of talking about
transformation so why should anyone
believe that this transformation is
actually happening well I often say to
the critics um hold on a minute so let's
just look at the data because I think we
we've made a a real effort to make as
much data as possible transparently
available for people to scrutinize us so
if I take something like revenues you
mentioned vast majority of our revenues
are still coming from combustible
cigarettes well I say hang on let's just
go back a bit we go back to 2015 which
is when we had our first launch of our
product on a national basis in Japan we
had zero percent of our revenues coming
from small smoke-free Alternatives in
2015 a hundred percent coming from
cigarettes if you fast forward to the
our last quarterly earnings and 2023 we
have now almost 35 percent of our net
revenues coming from smoke free
Alternatives and 65 coming from
combustible cigarettes that's in less
than a decade I mean the speed of that
transformation is incredible
unparalleled in any other industry so I
understand the skepticism but the skept
decision should be based on a good
understanding of the facts and the data
that we have made transparently
available
um Chris let me bring you in here now
because PMI is not the only
controversial company
um trying to remake themselves for
ethical or health reasons you know we're
talking about fossil fuels fast food
social media all of these things where
companies are trying to be more ethical
at least saying that they're trying to
be more ethical and healthy how do you
read that trend is it largely a PR move
or do you think that ethics does now
have more of a role in corporate life
um I think it's a bit of both um I think
the ones that I mean one that's often
cited as the most successful is a Danish
company called allstead
um I think I pronounced it right
um Olstead was Danish national oil and
gas and the price of natural gas
collapsed it went down 90 very quickly
and they were heading for Oblivion and
their credit rating went through the
floor
and in
unbelievable speed
um they ditch the oil and gas they moved
to wind turbines they ditched the name
they name themselves after a famous
Danish scientist and they're now pretty
much the number one in the world in wind
turbines and they actually got in that
market ahead of anybody else it was
forced by necessity
there are some though that
have failed and I think is that awful
word authenticity where you can smell
that this is genuine this is real
um are they really doing this are they
really
rolling this out or are they playing are
they seeking positive headlines but
they're not doing it really
um and I can think of a few like that
um can you give us an example of one
well one one that struggles with where
it's going
um is BP Beyond petroleum
was launched a big Fanfare we all at the
time my goodness you know BP Beyond
petroleum that's uh how on Earth can BP
not do oil I mean it doesn't seem
conceivable now the Danish did it so I
suppose that's a good example the BP a
huge company
um massive
um
how can they really do this and of
course recently
um they've pulled back they've pulled
back quite a lot
um almost I wouldn't say they've ditched
the policy that's probably unfair but
it's not a center stage as it was I
think though in this climate there are
lots of companies who
are responding to ethical issues
regulatory issues sometimes they go hand
in hand medical issues for a corporate
that's at the wrong end of the spectrum
producing things
that might be harmful or might do this
might do that
that's a very very uncomfortable place
to be in today's world I mean yeah you
know if we went back for 50 years
you didn't have shareholder activism you
didn't have people running on
Tennis Courts at Wimbledon trying to
disrupt tennis matches you didn't have
social media
you didn't have politicians who were
politicians in those days were a bit
more cowed towards business well now
they're not and and
you know the pressure to change is is
huge
and where Chris I hinted at a few of the
challenges that companies find whether
it's leadership from the top Associated
too much with one person shareholders
being activists regulatory concerns for
you you know having overseen so much of
pmi's own um transformation what do you
think are the biggest challenges that
you are still facing in stopping you
from going faster so so for us the
challenge is is predominantly in the
external world I think we've done a
really good job of embedding the idea of
transformation since the very beginning
internally so there isn't this concept
that it's one person's idea and
therefore you know when when he stepped
down as a CEO that it would it would
wither away that was absolutely not the
case we're already well on the track and
actually he became exact chair of our
board so is overseeing you know from
from the board perspective so I think we
did a good job of you know making the
entire company understand why this
strategy was the the right strategy
I think where we where we're struggling
is
um in the outside world the Public
Health Community regulators and policy
makers getting kind of stuck I think on
the potential challenges of such a
disruptive transformation the potential
downside of the new technologies that we
put on the market and they've kind of
lost sight a bit of the the opportunity
so the smokers the adult smokers who
could benefit the most from from our
transformation are kind of lost in the
arguments about youth use of products
and so on and I'm not minimizing that
these unintended consequences
um you know should be thought about and
should be taken care of but at the same
time we should also think about the
opportunity for individual adult smokers
and public health as a as a whole so I
think what we're trying to do now is
make sure that we're having a balanced
discussion so we're we're ensuring we're
talking about those opportunities as
well as the as the risks and you know
trying to make that a fact-based
discussion based on not just emotions we
we work on a very emotive topic and I'm
very sensitive to that but there are now
many facts from different countries that
show it is entirely possible to make um
cigarettes obsolete just need to look at
Sweden so Sweden has a long history of
an oral
um non-combustible tobacco product
called Swedish snooze and it's
essentially almost obliterated cigarette
smoking in in Sweden so they're now
almost at five percent smoking incidents
which is unheard of
um in the rest of the world so it's and
you see that corresponding to um the
lowest levels of smoking related
diseases in European Union among males
so you start to see the evidence
building that this strategy can work and
therefore transformation of my company
and other companies in the industry can
have a positive impact on public health
did you want to come in on that yeah I
think nobody should be under any
illusion a company
switching switching course ditching
something it's always done which is the
case
um it's incredibly hard
um you have a brand that's associated
entirely with cigarettes so I'm I'm not
one of those people there are people who
say
if you really meant it you'd do it
overnight I mean I've heard that
argument many times in relation to
Philip Morris
um
and then there's also another
constituency you've got to carry which
you can't lose sight of which is the
shareholders and the shareholders
invested
in a company that was making cigarettes
and was making money out of cigarettes
and that's what they liked I mean
whether they're right to do that or not
I don't know the same way that people
invested in arms companies and and other
companies that you know cause damage and
but they invested in it because it was a
cigarette company not because
it had heat not burn and products like
that
um so you have to lead people I think
there's a lot of hand leading here you
have to lead people by the hand
and the temptation
to ditch it but that must be very strong
and um you know in a way all credit
to people for holding their nerves but
there's a third option as well isn't
that you know you can stay your course
or you can ditch it or the third option
is to say that you're staying your
course but actually not doing be doing
as much as you could be so whitewashing
yeah I mean that's what critics of PMI
would often yeah I think saying all
these nice things but you're not
actually yeah delivering I think
yes and look there's a certain truth and
it might not be smoking in Sweden but
they're certainly smoking in Indonesia
and the Philippines and China and places
like that far more than here and
you know in a weird way you still have
growing markets in those places and I
mean
growing with versus your competitors and
you know so you're you're riding two
horses but
I mean I I suppose the the cynic in me
would say
I really want to see in
five years time
I'll give you five years
five years time well it's been going a
long time already I'll give you five
years
while I say it's very difficult I would
like it to be a bit quicker so so would
we and if I can just go back to a point
you made earlier I hear often people say
you should just sell your cigarette
business you should just get rid of it
so that you can focus only on these new
products and only on on transformation
and we have thought about this a lot
over the years and if you think about it
logically we we have a fiduciary
responsibility to shareholders yes so we
we have to return to shareholders and
any company that we sold the combustible
cigarette business would have a
fiduciary responsibility to their
shareholders to sell more cigarettes not
fewer so what we have done is we've
incentivized ourselves and all our
Senior Management are incentivized their
bonus um is is coming from selling more
smoke-free Alternatives and fewer
cigarettes is that a really all all
measurements yes yeah
exactly our transformation we have a
number of metrics and
associated with our transformation and
so our senior executives are being
incentivized for the right things if we
were to sell whether to private Equity
or another business they would be trying
to sell more cigarettes not fewer so
there's more Chris has just said he's
not looking for YouTube
what about what about this idea of you
increasing sales or cigarettes in
Indonesia Egypt Thailand turkey you know
all of these non-western countries
um where you are increasing cigarette
sales and when your Chief Financial
Officer was asked about this uh to the
by the financial times he said our
ambition is convert smokers to our
product which suggested that he wanted
to introduce people to cigarettes such
that he could then introduce them to
your smoke-free products I mean that
doesn't seem ethical at all because as a
doctor surely you would say it's better
to not Vape or not to useless than to
use these products at all so clearly the
best thing somebody can do is never to
start using a tobacco or nicotine
product and if they have they should
quit if you are an adult who smokes
these products are a much better
alternative than continuing to smoke but
if we look around the world not every
country has regulation and policy that
makes it easy to bring these new
products onto the market there's a
number of countries Singapore is one
example
um Brazil is another Mexico is another
these alternative products which science
shows are better than cigarette smoking
are banned but cigarettes are allowed
so what what choice do we have as a
company in countries like that is that
the case in all of the countries where
States not not all of them Indonesia for
example we have just launched um
no no we we have just uh launched our
heated tobacco product there and we're
we're saying that you could not be in
these markets at all right again we come
down to the fiduciary responsibility to
shareholders can it be in a rock and a
hard place that's why we're working
to help regulators and policy makers
understand the science so that they can
we don't care what they do in terms of
regulation for for cigarettes if you
know they want to put in place really
harsh restrictions that's a great thing
but what they should also do is allow
these smoke-free products
um as a place for people to to go if
they're not going to quit I think one
thing in PMI and Philip Morris's favor
is that
while in the industry and in this in the
city in Wall Street
the investment Community you're known
and obviously among
tobacco campaigners you're known for
cigarettes you're not in the same
position as some companies where they
are so identified in the name with the
harmful product that they've got you
know they're changing it I mean BP
I would argue this is in a more
difficult place
um
and I mean the one that comes to mind
which is similar is Diageo
um most people do not know what Diageo
is but they know what Johnny Walker is
and they know what Guinness is
um Diageo is going into
um alcohol-free Spirits alcohol-free
Gins so why is it but they can because
people don't really know what Diageo is
it's a holding name and in a way I think
you're in a similar and I think should
give you
give you heart that it can work yeah no
no I agree and we had to make I think
what what was quite a difficult decision
in the beginning of our transformation
to do with the brand and do we do we
accept that we're going to basically
throw our biggest brand almost under the
bus do we accept that we're going to
cannibalize our you know best-selling
product
um because that's the only way that
we're going to you know truly transform
and I think you know the decision was
made that yes that's a good thing we're
going we're going all in if you like if
you take the example that you did about
alcohol I think these are your alcoholic
and non-alcoholic drinks it's not like
they're trying to replace alcoholic
drinks with non-alcoholic drinks it's
it's you know a side-by-side strategy
ours is different ours is purely a
replacement strategy we we want to you
know basically make our old product
obsolete yeah I mean I I would it
reminds me a bit of
some of the sort of political statements
that you know
Boris Johnson might have made saying
well now we're going to be Net Zero by
so there'll be no no petrol cars no new
petrol cars in Britain by 2030. wow
and now as 2030 gets nearer people are
beginning to think hang on there are
enough charging points electric cars are
too expensive blah blah blah
um
so while I think it was in incredibly
Brave
for PMI to say this
I can't help thinking at the back of
some Minds maybe not yours within the
company there are some people saying I
wish we'd not said that I wish we're not
you do have a Target at you more about
20 a 50 of revenue from smoke freeze
products by 25 20 25 in 2025 we want to
see the majority we're on track
um here's the thing though so that you
make an interesting point about the role
that policy makers can can make so you
know the the statements made about
um going fully electric cars and
combustible engines will be no longer
allowed that's a government policy or it
could have been a government policy we
we were here a few years ago and our CEO
said I believe that cigarettes here in
the United Kingdom could be obsolete
within the next 10 to 15 years and I'd
be happy to have a conversation with
anybody about how we make that happen
not a single person picked up the phone
not a single person wrote to him and
said you know we would like to you know
sit down and discuss with you how this
could help happen so it's perfectly
possible for a government to say we're
going to and particularly here in the
United Kingdom which has a strong
culture of tobacco harm reduction and
embracing these products it would be
perfectly possible for a group of people
to sit down together and say okay how
are we going to make this happen how are
we going to make cigarettes obsolete but
for some reason there's not the will to
do it it is interesting I mean in my
yeah my lifetime
I was reading something the other day
actually but
I was born in 59 and in 59
smoking was everywhere everywhere
everyone smoked and I remember this is
going on memory lane I can remember
the smoking Carriage on the tube I can
remember I think I can remember people
smoking on planes
um which is disgusting
and you know I've watched this product
it's now virtually invisible you can't
there's no signs it's not visible in the
news agent it costs a lot of Fortune and
so in a way it's becoming obsolete it's
become an invisible problem yeah six
points six million people here in the
United Kingdom who still smoke
cigarettes they don't see them they
don't see you as not an invisible yeah
yeah but the thing is it's not visible
policy makers so much anymore so it was
kind of okay you know we'll just leave
it be can we finish on the idea of
metrics and Chris as well because more
you know you're mentioning of uh senior
Management's bonuses being pegged to
smoke free revenues it's the first time
I've heard of it no I didn't know so
um yeah I'm Keen to hear other metrics
that the company has and Chris from you
you know what would you be looking out
for maybe Chris you can start you know
in your in your experience as a business
journalist looking at different
Transformations successful and
unsuccessful what are the key melt
milestones and metrics that they have to
hit so that you'll judge that by
um oh gosh
um
well I think you're on track for one
which is the bulk the bulk of your
product is something else it's not
cigarettes it's going to be something
else
you know even 50 percent
I'd want to be getting to 60 and 70. I
feel more comfortable in that region
where I think well 70 well that's pretty
good so I'd be that would be one the
other would be which is a key one I
think this is a key one it's not
scientific
it's
the way you're perceived
um the way you're described in the media
we all have labels I mean the way
journalists work and the way it means
the way the Public Works everyone works
same way but they all say
Philip Morris maker and Marlborough or
Philip Morris the cigarette company if
that when that changes
and it won't be you that changes that
it'll be
external it'll be the perception of what
is it now
um
that I think would be remarkable
I I don't know I I think slowing down in
cigarette sales I think worldwide for
you I think that should
be a Target I don't think you can have
this duality of
producing
safe stuff eat not burn whatever you
want to call it and meanwhile the the
chart for cigarette sales continues to
rise maybe not in Britain or Europe but
in other places where yeah there are
rich let's face it there are issues
about health education there are issues
about
uh causality and cancer and things like
that we are much more ahead in developed
Nations than they are and
um
you know I want to see some progress
there
um
I don't know about the breakdown of the
workforce but that should be another
um how many people are
in cigarettes how many people are on the
other side so I I don't think there's
much to disagree with I would just um be
clear our cigarette sales are declining
so you may have countries or yeah
globally you may have problems in some
places where it's going up we're our
share of markets may you know change and
quarter to quarter a year to year but
overall they're they're declining on a
global basis so yes we're monitoring are
we selling fewer cigarettes we're
monitoring the net revenues we're
monitoring our spec our commercial
spends are spend on uh commercialization
r d r d 99 at 98 or 99 of our r d spend
is on smoke free Alternatives the the
remainder is just for regulatory science
that we need to do in certain countries
for combustibles
um so we're looking at a whole range of
different things and Publishing them we
are a US listed uh company so we're
subject to the rules of the SEC so to
your point we have to tell the truth
about our revenues we have no choice and
and people can go and look at it and
they can look at it on a quarterly basis
and see if we're progressing in the
right direction let me ask a question
though because this
and this is human nature so uh you know
you're not on the main board are you no
so the main board sits around the table
what's the first item
smoke free Alternatives always always
they almost never talk about the
combustible business I sit um in in
Senior Management meetings There is
almost no discussion about combustible
words I've been in the company 17 years
I have never worked on a project related
to combustible cigarettes but when they
meet for their monthly board meetings
and they're going through all the sales
figures and performance and profit and
things
is it what you call them combustibles
the first thing that will be discussed
is smoke free Alternatives really yes
well
gosh no no questions it's literally
speechless
flabbergasted well importantly for
another reason which is it might be
a
if that's true
but the fact is
from what we've said earlier is
so the bit that accounts for 65 percent
every news
it's talked about second if at all
and it's all everyone around the table
is focusing on the 35 yeah that seems a
bit strange well well here's the reason
we know how to make and sell cigarettes
we've been doing it for decades so
there's very it's a very stable kind of
business you you know you you know how
to run that business what we're learning
how to do is how to accelerate the
trajectory of smoke-free Alternatives so
that's where management time and focus
is is spent because that's the important
part of the future it's not the
combustible cigarettes the answer I I
answered partly in the question earlier
but another Matrix I would look for
would be
um level of investment so
um you know is it
is it a heat but not burn Factory or is
it a new cigarette factory yeah
um and how does that work yeah so again
we're publishing our manufacturing
infrastructure
um we uh published the number of
um smokers who have converted to the
product on a quarterly basis the number
of markets where we've launched the
product more than 70 now more than half
of those 70 in non-oecd countries so we
you know if there's other things people
would like to see we're happy to look
into you know um and Publishing those as
well but I think we've done a really
good job of of figuring out the things
that people really can monitor that
matter to people and and Publishing
those I just I hope people go and look
at them
Chris Moira will have to leave it there
but thank you so much for joining this
special episode of spectator TV and
thank you for watching at home if you
want to find out more about PMI do check
out that interview that Fraser Nelson
did with yashik orjek uh it's called
it's a spectator podcast uh so you can
get that wherever you get your podcast
from them we'll put a link in the
description as well thanks very much